and joining us now with reaction Florida
Congressman Byron Donalds you know we
live in a woke World Congressman we live
in a world of cancer culture right
how come the one exception to that
always seems to be
black conservatives where it's open
season because this is repulsive this is
not the first attack against you as a
matter of fact every African-American
conservative that I know goes through
some form of this why is it tolerated
because it shouldn't be tolerated
well I mean look Sean I think it's
tolerated from the left because black
conservatives we're narrative Busters we
actually demonstrate a completely
different world view than stuff that the
left and the Democrats like to put out
but to be honest with you I'm actually
sick and tired of talking about this
kind of stuff you know this is something
where my staff and I kind of got
together and they felt so strongly about
talking about this because Sean what
most people don't know is I have black
staffers and I have white staffers they
come together they work hard for me at
my congressional district every single
day and I really feel bad for them and
the other young black of people out
there who are starting to become more
conservative what stuff like this is
about is about stopping them from
expressing their political thoughts
their political world views for me I'm a
member of Congress I'll deal with it
with the hot takes and the shots because
that's what I signed up for but for
other black people in America who were
starting to come around to conservatism
and a limited in a limited government
philosophy this kind of stuff is to
suppress their our thoughts and their
viewpoints and I'm sad for them because
that shouldn't be tolerated in America
let me ask you about the debt ceiling uh
we have what 33 trillion dollars in debt
it is not an imminent crisis we could
probably go a number of months maybe
even till June however uh it's coming
it's pending My Hope Is Republicans will
have a plan stay United will that happen
yeah that's going to happen we're going
to have a plan on this but what the
White House has put out there saying
there's going to be no negotiations
that's just insane that makes no sense
at all what we should be doing is making
sure at a minimum that we get rid of all
this coveted spending out of the
Baseline that will go a long way to
bringing some spending restraint back to
Washington D.C and then we have to start
coming up with other strategies because
just continue it continuously going to
expanding the credit card is not going
to be what's in the best interest of the
American people but we're going to have
a plan we're going to stand together and
do what's right on behalf of America
well you absolutely have become a rising
star in the Republican caucus uh we
appreciate your conservative views your
good fight and keep us up to speed and
thank you as always for being with us
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else